ces images ont été tournées au cours de
la pulvérisation aérienne d'un vignoble
1970 dans le vignoble bordelais un
hélicoptère pulvérise des pesticides
rapide pratique tout le village est en
admiration devant cette modernité la
dangerosité potentielle de ces produits
n'est absolument pas abordée dans ces
années là et face au climat girondins
très humide
les viticulteurs ont largement recours
aux herbicides insecticides et
fongicides de synthèse en 1990 première
alerte
il y aurait des traces de fongicides
dans le vin dans ses bouteilles un
fongicide dont on parle beaucoup ce
matin à bordeaux dans l'approché me
donne avant j 6 2 reconnu cancérogène
probable et perturbateurs endocriniens
interdite en france depuis 2008 mais
dans le bordelais comme ailleurs les
produits phytosanitaires sont devenus la
norme pour la majorité des viticulteurs
au début des années 2000 certains
journalistes commencent à s'intéresser
aux effets secondaires de ces
traitements chimiques en donnant la
parole aux agriculteurs bio peu nombreux
dans le bordelais à l'époque le père de
françois a commencé à s'inquiéter des
incidences de certains produits sur la
santé du jour au lendemain plus de
produits chimiques de synthèse
herbicides fongicides engrais uniquement
des molécules naturelles est beaucoup
beaucoup de travail manuel les années
passent et l'inquiétude autour des
dangers des pesticides chimiques
augmente
une enquête menée par des associations
écologiques européenne révèle que tous
les vins sont contaminés par des résidus
de pesticides 2008 l'état intervient en
lançant le plan ecophyto objectif
réduire de 50 % l'utilisation des
pesticides d'ici 2018
impossible selon les viticulteurs pas
assez contraignant selon certains
agronome une bonne partie des
viticulteurs ont besoin d'une loi claire
et précise qui fixe le nombre maximal de
traitement par an pour aller dans cette
voie là n'iront que contraints par le
gie slater
la prise de conscience au niveau
national se fera en 2016 avec l'émission
cash investigations chiffres à l'appui
le bordelais est sur le podium des
régions viticoles les plus gourmandes en
produits phytosanitaires réaction de la
population mais aussi des viticulteurs
eux mêmes c'est une démarche encore
inédite des grands vins de bordeaux dans
la lutte contre les pesticides
je vous le disais le syndicat des
bordeaux et bordeaux supérieur met en
place cinq mesures pour concrètement
diminuer les produits phytosanitaires
preuve d'une volonté de changement pour
les un coup de com sans effet pour les
autres une chose est certaine depuis ces
scandales la part de vignes bio dans le
vignoble bordelais a augmenté passant de
0 9% en 2000 à 7 % en 2017
ça reste tout de même moins que la
moyenne nationale 9 % de la superficie
du vignoble français est en certifié bio
[Musique]